1975 c'est tf1 c'est aussi l'arrivée à
paris ce matin de christine freesia à
droite et d'evelyne leclerc à gauche
elles ont 24 et 25 ans elles viennent de
notre station régionale de nice côte
d'azur pour en quelque sorte animé et re
soirée sur tf1 écrit nice une première
comment concevez vous votre rôle
d'hôtesse pickering et bien on va
essayer je crois dans la mesure du
possible de faire quelque chose de tout
à fait nouveau on nous a demandés nous
intéressait beaucoup plus aux émissions
qui seront présentés d'assister aux
projections de france ou de faire des
interviews aussi en fin de peine
je pense qu'il y aura une participation
personnelle beaucoup plus important que
nous apporterons notre avis et
raconteront des anecdotes qui se seront
passées au moment du tournage ou bien
nous donnerons jugement personnel sur
telle ou telle émission
vous pensez avoir des invités par
exemple combien c'est très peu si les
réalisateurs démission ou bien des
les artistes et gens qui participent à
l'émission si nous passons un film très
connus essayer d'avoir la vedette
principale ou bien le metteur en scène
je crois que ça intéressera les gens va
un petit peu l'envers du décor d'une
émission qu'il présentait les premiers
pas de cette nouvelle formule
dès le premier jour de tf1 rendez vous
donc avec christine freesia et et vignes
leclerc lundi 6